this I knew at a very early age
the most cultured country in the world
built Auschwitz
the old there's this old question how
did the people who gave us Beethoven and
Bach
give us Auschwitz
and I I always found it's an interesting
question but it's it's somewhat of a
non-sequitur
why does having Bach and Beethoven
inoculate you against being come
becoming evil
the the ease with which a civilization
can turn morally
that's what Germany taught and I see
that happening in the United States
this I always believed was the kindest
country I know it has rotten people in
it just as rotten countries have kind
people in it but as a country
when people wanted help after
earthquakes they didn't go to they
didn't ask for Belgium
when people uh use the flag to Rebel for
Liberty like in Hong Kong they they
didn't take the Swedish flag right
but
look what's happening
all right Prager here we go again I will
tell the people that we had a moment to
chat before we just sat down and we
realized that we have not seen each
other in person in about 14 or 15 months
because it was a few weeks before my
first son was born and you said to me
well why don't I let you tell the people
what you said to me right before the
church I said I thought I had in fact
seen your kids well they were but you
haven't as far as I could tell so you
may have thought that you've seen them
yes so it shows you I don't know if this
is a good or bad thing the power of
photos yeah I've sent you a lot of
pictures yeah I've sent you into a lot
of people from the beginning exactly and
then I couldn't remember if you had seen
them either that is really funny we
should ask them yeah we should ask the
kids well they're not talking exactly
they're not talking well no no I then I
said to you have you well do you
remember holding them because I know
yeah that would be a giveaway yeah and
we have no regulations yeah I remember
holding photos yeah yeah okay that's
fair enough but yeah I did see EU I I
had I truly think this was one of the
most memorable nights of my life I had
you and Jordan Peterson over just two
weeks or so before my first son was born
and David and I were basically able to
ask you to everything about life and we
talked about everything it was one of
the most yeah it was truly it was one of
the most meaningful conversations in my
life that's nice and we realized
remember what we realized that night
about me you and Jordan that we have 14
years separating each of us I was 46 at
the time Jordan was 60 and you were 74
at the time which is just sort of
interesting that there's the same that
is fascinating yeah but you said as I
you know we were about to have kids and
you said to me something to the effect
of you better enjoy it now yeah well I
was more specific yeah can you clean it
up for me well uh but yes yeah look uh
I'm a big big believer in acknowledging
reality I don't sugarcoat and I don't
make worse
and uh as I was saying to you beforehand
and I'm gonna I'm gonna I think I might
write a column on this
the notion that you can have it all is
absurd
and if when the feminist movement said
to him and you could have it all is one
who's one of the indications that it was
an immature movement immature in terms
of thought and and and and emotion even
you can have some of everything you
can't have everything if you want to be
a parent and you did
and Dave did obviously that you guys you
you wanted to be parents
that means that the the
happy-go-lucky let's do whatever we want
anytime we want life is over it is it's
over here I'm sorry and and and so uh so
many immature people young people today
don't want to give that up they think
that will bring them happiness in the
long run it's fun on any given day but
the long run to not have children to not
have the prospect of grandchildren uh
it's such an
a poorer life do you think you can have
it for moments have everything for
moments yeah because I will tell you one
one thought that I'm having a lot lately
is that and I and I don't want to jinx
it I almost don't want to say this out
loud I'm sure there's an English right
for it yeah
I have the stuff that I want in my life
right now my life is good and my family
your life is good my work is good my
colleagues are good that's right but
it's making me a little nervous
I know I've never had that okay so you
are this is almost redundant a neurotic
Jew no I'm not a neurologist
I don't have that I don't have that
thing yeah oh if you don't have it then
what you're saying you do no no no no I
have this notion notion that you're
jinxing it yeah is neurotic that's
neurology okay yeah we found minor OCS
no you're a person
that's correct you are about as healthy
a guy as I know in all seriousness
uh but the I never I
I have quote unquote it all in in that
sense but I don't have it all because
I've given up X Y and Z for family for a
career for intimacy for friends uh you
know do I want to sleep in many
Saturdays of course I do but I but I I
teach at the synagogue that I've that
Alan Estrin Steve Mormon I founded uh in
in L.A uh but but it's worth it because
I I love that community
so I I so long ago made peace with you
you give up to gain no you know it's so
I it's so funny people say no pain no
gain and they always meet it with regard
to exercise it's true with everything in
life you're learning it now and by the
way wait till they get to be teenagers
oh no then you may end up neurotic they
may cause it
it's so funny because I I really don't
consider myself a neurotic person and
I've no and I usually and I don't and I
don't worry I generally don't worry
about I worry about the future of the
world oh you know you know that's my
answer when people say how are you right
for years I've been saying better than
my country
so you and I share that I'm not worried
about that much in my day-to-day life
basically especially now I'm not but I
worry about the nature of the world
where the countries
that is a legit worry is it how do you
you've got a couple years I mean how do
you where do you know if it's just with
you all the time right this one is not a
matter of a couple of years on you this
I knew at a very early age
uh the most cultured country in the
world built Auschwitz
you the old there's there's this old
question how did the people who gave us
Beethoven and Bach
give us Auschwitz
and I I always found it's an interesting
question but it's it's somewhat of a
non-sequitur
why does having Bach and Beethoven
inoculate you against being come
becoming evil the the ease with which a
civilization can turn morally that's
what Germany taught and I see that
happening in the United States
this I always believed was the kindest
country I know it has rotten people in
it just as rotten countries have kind
people in it but as a country
when when people wanted help after
earthquakes they didn't go to they
didn't ask for Belgium
when people use the flag to Rebel for
Liberty like in Hong Kong they they
didn't take the Swedish flag
but
look what's happening do you think that
it maybe is just exactly what was going
to happen with the nature of the
internet that because all of us have the
world in our pocket all the time and the
ability to get information out all the
time and fight all the time and see
things that we didn't see all the time
and see behind the curtain of the lies
of the media just the Litany of things
that now we all have sort of stuffed in
our brains that the moment that we're at
was in some ways inevitable because of
the internet yeah because there's just
so much information there it feeds the
division the algorithms all of those
things that we were going to get to this
weird spot in some ways I I see the
decline in my beloved country as
independent of the internet
when I was at Columbia University in the
70s that's way before the internet I was
I was taught
that uh America was an imperialist
country I was taught that men and women
are basically the same
and I even wrote about it I I I from in
the 80s
the The Roots the The Roots way way
transcend internet so you think it was
inevitable anyway because of the
education system or the institutional
collapse but not necessarily because of
the internet well at Columbia there were
kids spelling America on in graffiti
with a K yeah
that's 1972.
and I I remember thinking are you out of
your mind do you know what fascism is
that you you can or Nazism you because
that was the German spelling you know as
if we're becoming Nazi Germany
so how do you
you
Reagan explained it we are always one
generation away from losing Freedom
Deuteronomy explains it you know I I
have my series of Bible commentaries
yeah right there I'm very touched yes I
am touched well this is my life's
project it's your studio oh okay
whose name's on the building okay yeah
that's a good point I didn't think of
that it just shows I'm not Mr primadonna
but uh Deuteronomy said you will talk
about these things that is God's
teachings
when you lie down when you rise up when
you walk by the way when you go to sleep
in other words if you don't teach your
children good values all the time it's
over
and that's what that's what happened and
I'll tell you who did it and I knew it
when I was a kid
it was the the generation we call the
greatest Generation they were they were
the greatest Generation in many ways but
not as parents
they their motto and by the way I said
this in my 20s when I started lecturing
I would look at these people my parents
generation I'd say
you always say you gonna you give our
generation everything you didn't have
the problem is you didn't give us
everything you did have
which was love of country love of God
and uh the the
self-control and all those values so if
you saw that when you were 20 so now
we're talking you know 50 some odd years
ago you must really see it when you know
so I'm I'm a Gen X guy so at 47 I'm
right now in the thick of what is
supposed to be the group of people
running the show at this point and yet
we're not we have an 80 plus year old
who's President and another 80 plus year
old who and I'm not an ageist of course
but the shift has not occurred where we
have sort of younger people running
things I also think that is adding now
to some of the tension oh I wonder
I I don't know why exactly because I
remember and I'm not saying this because
I'm old now but I remember the motto one
of the stupid many stupid mottos of my
generation the Baby Boomers never trust
anyone over 30. and I was 20 when I
first heard it and I thought what are
you out of your mind I trust Moses he's
he's 3 000 years old I remember thinking
that he's really over 30. but what what
stupid line is that I don't hey let's
say everyone over 60 was removed from
all public office in America nothing
nothing
I think there's a slim chance we'd get
some change on the margins maybe just
just getting rid of some of the the like
yeah so so you'd have you yeah we would
just get that you know I just had
middle-aged fools instead of old fools
yeah well look it's so funny because
you're doing this with me we're talking
about the the
ills of the world but you always have a
smile on your face I see you at my house
you have a smile oh you know and you've
been talking about happiness forever
it's an interesting dichotomy you're
telling me on one hand you're worried
about the world and I know you are it's
your life's work to correct that
and yet you really if someone said to me
who's the happiest person you know it's
probably you right well you know there's
a whole other series of people that
think you're very scary you're a
right-wing Maniac or something right yes
like they know me or even know what I
say they got all their material from
another left side right it's very you'll
find this very touching because you're
very close to Jordan
so uh so Jordan Peterson obviously he
was at a prageru Gala about a year and a
half ago
and we have a wonderful dialogue and I'm
of course a big fan of Jordan
and he to his credit stayed afterwards
to take pictures with people and talk
with people and and I I was very
impressed with that because a lot of
speakers leave and I I do what he does I
stay I hang around but of course at a
Prager event I'm going to hang around
okay
anyway he walked over to me I've never
told this publicly I don't think he'd
mind
but you're so close to him it's
mind-blowing what you just said
he said something to this effect I'm
paraphrasing
you know Dennis
I don't know anybody who is as intense
about the big issues
and As You Are
and who is as happy as you are who was
as light-hearted
and I never thought of that that I'm
sort of unique I I don't know if I'm
unique but sort of unique in that way
it's a a it's my temperament but b i
cultivated it
I hate being unhappy I really hate it
yeah
and uh I I am able to compartmentalize
that's why my answer better than my
country is such an honest answer
if am I quote unquote depressed about
the state of America yes
but am I depressed no right
and a lot of people can't do that that's
right they can't disconnect those well
that's right they can't compartmentalize
if you can't compartmentalize you cannot
be happy
otherwise every human being who has had
tragedy is doomed you know how many
parents I know who have lost a child
a lot of them have been able and it's
truly to their great credit
to to walk around with it with an
essentially happy disposition and that's
a little searing pain a human can have
which you can only now imagine it's it's
be it's it's the ultimate nightmare we
had to take Luke to the hospital out of
nowhere one night something wasn't right
he was a little pal and kind of closing
his eyes we thought something was going
on and I
maybe I said this once on camera this is
about six months ago and I we were in
the car
and I I spoke to God to whatever extent
that I speak to God and I said you could
take me right now like all right just
don't take him yeah yeah
oh you know that gives me the chills
when I brought my first son home from
the hospital I remember in the getting
out of the car crossing the street into
my house
and thinking
I have never been as unafraid as I am
now if a car were to come all I know is
this child will be safe and I'm okay if
I'm hit
I'm just echoing what you said yeah if
you can't compartmentalize you you can't
uh you can't achieve happiness there's
too much pain in one's own life or in
the life of the society
that if if the and by the way
compartmentalize is a good term because
what sank the Titanic was that the
compartments did in fact leak one into
the next had they not it would not have
sunk is that something that you think
and I actually don't want to do much
political stuff with you today but is
that something you think
conservative-minded people can do better
than lefties our whole life is in
politics yeah
if the country were in good shape I
wouldn't talk about politics five
minutes a day yeah
I I am forced to because I want to help
save this country but
that is their meaning
Revolution is their meaning that's not
our meaning
we get meaning from a whole bunch of
things even Hobbies yeah it's funny
because when I had you and Jordan over
in that night it was mostly focused on
family and whatever but like had we
talked politics it would have almost
seemed ridiculous I I don't the word
Trump did not come up the name DeSantis
did not that's right and it would have
seemed sort of ridiculous why would I
waste my time with you guys talking
about that stuff not to say it isn't
important but it is a it is a
compartment not the yes but it is for
the the further the left you go the more
making Revolution Is Everything
and and therefore and therefore politics
is everything
and that's a uh
sorry it's very embarrassing when my own
phone rumbles you know I
could be going on here yeah it's really
a riot yeah
no no here's the joke it'll be it'll you
know what it'll say on my phone scam
likely I get more calls from Mr likely
than from my wife they're trying to get
you now yeah it could be Sue sending you
a picture of my children and anything
that is entirely accurate yes I think
almost every time I have you on camera I
repeat the same story but I think it's
always worth repeating and we can only
do it for a moment if you want but the
time that when I did the why I left the
left video and we were just getting to
know each other and it was the first
time I was on your radio show I think
that afternoon and I was dealing with a
lot of hate and all that stuff and I
said to you and I didn't know you the
way I know you now and I said Dennis you
know what do you do about the hate and
security and all that stuff and you said
to me it was just so perfect you said
Dave you know I can't do this is not a
great Dennis breaker impression but he
said Dave you know I'm doing my show
from the same studio for 30 years and I
guess one day somebody could be waiting
for me outside and hacked me with the
machete but when it it's your time to go
it's your time to go and I just and to
me that sums you up like that that and
your smile about that right you know
like I know by the way it's an extremely
rational uh effect that this this notion
that I can protect myself if somebody
really wants to to harm me is absurd how
often do you read and so and so and his
three bodyguards were killed right right
you know
for whatever reason I do elicit a lot of
hate but not the that that level for
whatever reason I I and I'm not sure why
I'm a pretty effective voice against the
left and but I'm not complaining
certainly about that fact uh but
I'm I'm anti-worrying worrying truly is
worthless
I I have a whole Theory like I do on
almost everything here's my theory on
worrying
if people people should monitor how
often have they worried and the thing
they worried about actually occurred you
will find what a small percentage of
time that is so then you've truly just
created misery for yourself for no
reason and if it does happen did the
worrying help
usually not I'm gonna guess yes it
probably made it worse to some extent
yes it's I'm not saying you don't take
precautions and you don't you know I I
have earthquake insurance I had
earthquake insurance before the
Northridge Earthquake
what do you do about a society that
you're worried about
as someone that doesn't want to worry
and doesn't want to be neurotic and
wants to fight for the things like what
what do you do for the average person
that's watching this or that does care
about politics that cares about the
stuff
I actually have an answer the only
antidote
to worry
or better to misery over the state of of
the society is to fight that is the only
antidote
tuning out doesn't work
because they'll come to you where you're
tuned out yeah you think you're tuning
out at a baseball game then they're
going to put black lives matter on on
the pitcher's mound or or in the uh you
know in the field goal or area what is
it touchdown what is Enzo in the end
zone
so you can't tune out it doesn't work
you have children you're going to tune
out and then they come home and they
hate your guts because because you voted
Republican
society's going to catch up with you the
only antidote is to fight so as you see
now the country going in different
directions and and I mean that I mean
that sort of philosophically but also
geographically right I mean I lived here
I'm one of a million some odd people
that have now left California and moved
to Florida
to me when I come back here I feel no
it's it's great to see you and some of
my friends here but I feel no connection
with this place that's fascinating and I
and I don't mean this as cold as it's
going to sound but I don't really care
about it yeah meaning why should I care
if they've made their choice now I get
there's millions of good people here
eight movies there are eight million
Republicans here right more than any
other state right so but what so what
how do you piece that together in in
terms of the United States I I want you
to know I am
um
periodically praised by strangers oh you
know I want you to know really salute
you for staying in California and
fighting I'm not in California uh I'm
fighting but I'm California is lost okay
it is a given uh a a a vicious
party runs my state
and and Oregon and Washington and and
Illinois and and New York I mean the a
lot of states
Minnesota uh so I I am here because
there are so many people I love who are
here and I as I mentioned I created a
synagogue which I am very devoted to
you you promised me to create me one if
I I told you I don't remember I I
believe you it's not it's not not
tempting I I missed you know we we just
went through the the high holidays here
and I missed going
yeah yeah well I I
so I have a very very wonderful life
here it's a very odd
I wouldn't say cognitive dissonance it's
just an odd contradiction so to speak to
have a great life in a miserable place I
I I acknowledge it you Newsome just
announced
I mean that he's he is uh vetoing a bill
that would uh allow or creating of
signing a bill that would fine any
school that banned any book uh about
race or sex
there is no time in the history of the
world that schools have not banned
certain books yes
that's right there was a children's
section in the library right that means
a lot of books were banned you mean your
Elementary School didn't have mineconf I
well listen here's the irony
probably would if you want to read mind
confidence read mine come
but we're not we're not going to give
you uh fellatio books right I mean I
mean this is
what what the the robbing children of
their innocence
is the somebody what it's what was the
term I've called the left sick for some
time now and I mean it literally
they they a pathocracy
it was a good term I don't know who came
up with it because it's like this
pathological thinking that then gets
institutionalized yes that's right yeah
that's what it is
you know we're going to have
five-year-olds with guys dancing in in
in women's clothing
oh you'll get a kick out of this so I
don't remember the verse but there is a
verse in Deuteronomy
a man shall not wear women's clothing
and a woman shall not wear beds clothing
I I have to remember the Numbers
Deuteronomy something something
so there are a lot of Christians who
will have I think it's from John John 1
8 is it I I does anybody here know that
there's a famous one and uh about God
giving his once only son to I love that
the biblical scholar is asking the
lighting guy if he knows what oh
316 yeah so John 3 16. New Testament I
don't know as well as the Old Testament
yeah
all right you're about I I rehearsed
Nathan on that yeah that's good so the
so a lot of people have a bumper sticker
let's say John 3 16.
I I want to have a bumper sticker
Deuteronomy this whatever that is and
then people say what the hell is that
and they'll look it up at you know
people don't know that the Bible forbids
that as an example then you'll have a
real problem in California well never no
one here is religious so it would be all
right yeah well yeah first of all you're
right most people don't know what
Deuteronomy is yeah so I could put it up
there and it wouldn't matter you know
speaking of the gender thing you'll find
this interesting just at a philosophical
level I think I was a few months ago uh
we had my sister and her kids over and
she's got three young kids and their
middle son is about six years old and
I'm sitting in the pool with him and it
suddenly struck him that there's no
mother at my house and he said to me
he said to me you have Justin and Luca
here but there's no Mommy here
and and he said where's the mommy
and I had this really interesting moment
because you know what do you answer so
my answer was
um basically I did I grabbed a ball or
something and I threw it to like change
the topic for a second because I knew it
was not my place to give the answer oh
so I punted it now the irony of course
well because the irony is I he's my
nephew I love him I have his best
interests in mine but it's not my place
as the uncle to to say when it is for
him to learn about such things right
right so I said to my sister as they
were leaving I said hey by the way he
asked me this question you have no no
pressure for me I'm just saying he asked
and we'll see if it ever comes up again
as far as I know it has him but I really
thought I did the right thing there and
I suspect the way you're nodding at me
probably yes I guess well it was a very
Noble uh answer uh uh well not a not
Noble non-answer
you see
you
you are a sort of a victim
of what the left is done with the whole
LGBT thing do you know I only wish I it
is recorded somebody who did
20 years of research would find that
at least 15 years ago I said on a number
of occasions why is there a t with LGB
what does t have to do with LGB
nothing
and L and G claim
this is how we are
uh uh what is what is what does gay have
to do with trans
and the country is not comfortable with
trans
as and correctly so at the very minimum
with children
how someone feels an adult no you're 30
years old and you say you know have a
nice life fine but but cutting off 18
year old girls breasts is our form of
clitoridectomy what what Muslims and
some Muslim many Muslims but not all in
Africa do where they cut off a girl's
clitoris at I don't know 12 years old
whatever it is we we are no better I
mean people need something we have
devolved in in the course of a few years
to the level of the clitoridectomy and
then they call it affirming care which
is an incredible play on words right
it's the least affirming thing well
right if you're gender affirming what
you say to a 60 year old who says she's
a boy
uh we want to affirm that you're a girl
that's that's gender that would be
affirming chopping their genitals
probably not that affirmative no yeah
but that but
generally speaking conservative I think
in a conservatives I say with this wide
sense of that word are not very good at
controlling language around this stuff
right we're always playing defense on
this right don't say gay and then we're
all like ah what do we do with that
they they own language I mean look you
know the the viral video with me on Bill
Maher yes we played it many times and I
deserve a lot of credit for it
just for the the the the two percent of
American that is unaware of it
less than four years ago I was on his
show he said oh you know Trump lies
Trump lies he said well it doesn't
compare to the left slides he goes like
what like America systemically racist
and Men menstruate
the the panel left and the whole
audience and he and he people have seen
it and he goes Dennis
where'd you get that from
it went from what the hell are you
talking about to of course men
menstruate in two years they are
literally that's how much they own the
language they are literally putting
tampons in boys that's correct yes this
is the generation that's going to have
to fight for America perhaps one day do
you think there's going to be a lot of
people that are young now that are going
to be seriously angry and yes it's
already happening yeah that when they're
putting their parents into old age homes
they are not going to uh the Cadillac of
old age homes I mean they are going to
be basically pushing them off the bridge
I mean that somewhat metaphorically but
that they are just going to say wow you
did none of the things that were that
were important to protect well it's
already happening where you have a fair
number of these poor souls who had their
breasts cut off or their male genitals
cut off
and they're suing the Despicable uh
therapists
who see them for an hour and say yeah Oh
no you're you're definitely a boy Jordan
calls them butchers and now he's got the
Canadian Board of Psychiatry after him
that's right Canada
you know I I have no idea if it's a
consolation or not Canada is worse
when at when Justin Trudeau
said to the Striking truckers which is
now like ancient history but it's a year
and a half ago or two years maybe
uh
that uh who he said you must take a get
a vaccine or you're fired
and uh they said no that's why they went
on strike and they could not have access
to their own money in their own bank
accounts that's scary do you think in
some respects these guys are overplaying
their hand and they may cause enough of
it yeah I think if the Le um yes you're
right it's nice because I am not I do
not look at life through rose-colored
glasses
I think the trans issue and and I think
that there is a you know I'm thinking of
so many things that's why I'm moving
from one to another but let me be more
careful
I if the left
Founders it will be on the trans issue
uh most Americans do not are not
prepared to say men give birth
they know that there is a certain uh big
lie involved there and they're not
prepared to go that far
they do not believe that five-year-olds
should be taught that you might be a boy
or you might be a girl they do not
believe five-year-olds should have drag
queen story hours
or a very sexual books read to them uh
in sixth grade
and the proof I have is that the New
York Times is starting to publish a few
columns
from you know guest columnists saying
you know we we have to understand
there's a Middle Road here and they just
had a piece in the New York Times uh
well you know I don't know I don't I I'm
no right winger and I can't stand the
right wing but
you know we're going too far on the left
but is that their trick is that the the
left and the machine's trick of always
maintaining power meaning they drag us
all to the precipice of hell with all of
this stuff and then suddenly right
before we go off the cliff the New York
Times pulls back a tiny bit but they've
already dragged us this far another one
you could give is right here in this
state they were about to pass a bill in
the California legislature about if you
did not affirm your child's gender
identity they were going to literally
let the state take your children away so
Gavin Newsom at the last second vetoed
it not because he doesn't give in to the
woke and push the woke in every moment
but it's their way of suddenly you may
be a hunter drag you and drag you
welcome to The Inferno and then at the
last moment they give you a little fire
retardant or something so you don't know
that's fair that may well be I uh so
even then putting that argument aside
uh uh I do believe
that this could be their Achilles heel
the the problem is the liberal
my problem is not the left
the left is the left
as I say almost every day on my radio
show the left votes its values the right
votes its values liberals do not vote
their values
liberals my whole almost my whole
extended family is liberal sweet people
and and I mean that and and they they
are convinced the right is their enemy
zagosh it's a very famous uh line in
French there were no enemies on the left
that is what the liberal believes
all my enemies are on the right
and we see this consistently I mean a
guy like Bill Maher who was in essence
mocking you for that yeah and I brought
it up didn't I did I I think I brought
it up to to bill when I sat down with
him on his podcast about that moment
yeah and I think he kind of like whisked
it off a little bit that's interesting
um but he then just two weeks ago was
saying that he wishes he wants Gavin
Newsom to run for president and it's
like he's a lit he's not a crazy leftist
lunatic right you would describe him
basically right right is it crazy he
left this lunatic
and he wants him well there is proof
that is exactly right so you're saying
in essence you're saying the true
lefties they're telling us what they
believe and they're doing right it's the
waffle people that's right that yeah but
how do we get hey I was one and here I
am so there is a way to get him
so my view of people like you is this
whenever someone comes over to me
at that an airport as a classic example
or obviously after a speech just want
you to know Dennis you changed my life
and I I give them an answer which they
may think I'm just being sweet I swear
before God I mean it literally
I tell them and I say to you
you get at least 50 percent of the
credit
because I have been saying these things
I'm just one example there are so many
Jordan and others but
I have been saying this for decades
and vast numbers of people their lives
have not changed so obviously you right
the credit if if Dave Rubin personified
Humanity
we have no troubles it's kind of funny I
was just thinking you know after touring
with Jordan for so long and I've done
plenty of events with you I've never
seen someone go up to either you and
Jordan been like you know I've been
listening to you guys for a long time
I've read all the books right watch
Alexis no effect didn't do anything for
me exactly
exactly has anyone ever done anything
like that like you know then it's like
this happiness thing okay yeah I have
yes as it happens so I did an event in
Minnesota uh for my local station it was
ilhan Omar wasn't it she read your book
yeah yeah right no no this was it's
related it's not exactly that so the
event was at a very very uh plush Cigar
Lounge
and it was really just for how many
people can you fit in so about a hundred
people they paid you know a good money
for the station to raise money and I I
go there and I speak
and people were sitting outside it was
not obviously uh winter
and so there were young a lot of you
know guys in their 20s sitting out there
and having a drink or smoking a cigar or
both
and the guy looks at me
and he goes
Prager
I go yes and the way he asked it I then
said is that good or bad and he said bad
ah and that was basically it and that
was it yes it's just hilarious it was
that's the closest I've ever gotten to
your uh you know I just want you to know
I've heard you all these years you
haven't had it what that's much effect
on me yeah
that also I think tells us something a
little bit about how people behave I
guess uh I guess this is what I was
trying to say about the online thing
earlier that there's a behavior pattern
that's developing online Jordan also
talks about this that it's becoming
pathological that you can just all day
long hate you hate you you're mean but
all these awful things where in real
life this sort of thing just simply does
not happen even if you go to an event
where you're protested you know it's
like they'll scream and whatever but
it's you know the the idea that it would
really escalate or something like that
it's not it's not non-existent but right
the keyboard has given us a certain
level of force field in a way what is
depressing
is obviously it has nothing to do with
violence but
I actually read comments I I not just on
things about me or things I I write I
read comments all the time that is
really an insight into the public
because they're Anonymous and especially
in the case of the New York Times
readers you have to be a New York Times
subscriber to make a comment so that to
me would be a more valuable version of
it oh that's right it is very valuable
and and stuff that I see there
I'll give you an example I did a whole
show on this
some some writer wrote about how uh I
think is I presume a woman she's not
going to have children because of uh
climate change
and oh I remember this so this a couple
months ago right oh even more than that
but but within the last year
and so I read I always click on that you
can click on three things newest
uh New York Times editor's Choice
reader's choice I always click on
reader's Choice the ones that the reader
the comments the readers most like
and one after another went like this
uh more than anything I have always
hoped to have grandchildren
but my daughter usually their daughter
my daughter or my daughter and her
husband
because of global warming are not having
children
and I salute them for that decision
that that is what I mean mythology Jews
after the Holocaust had children and
these people based on computer models at
Oxford are not
these are sickos
yeah but but deprogramming somebody from
that level oh no it's it's hopeless do
you think that's in some ways also why
there's such an assault on children
because if you can break the child in
this case let's say an 18 year old girl
who suddenly is saying she can't have
children because of climate change that
that's a very easy way of then breaking
the adult who may have been more uh less
susceptible to these ideas just by age
you know what I mean like if you get the
child now the parent has to kind of
defend that yeah well only because
parents are weak yeah if my child said
I'm not having children because of
global warming I'd say well I I was a
pretty I'm a failure as a parent if you
think that way I really failed I I
wouldn't I I the idea I I have real
contempt for this because it's my child
uh I will not stand up for what I
believe then then you don't believe what
you believe in
I love my children I'm not going to
compromise on what I believe because my
child feels differently maybe that's
part of the reason my children still
respect me because because they know
that's true
do you think it's possible that we're
not a serious enough country anymore to
fix some of these Grand things the big
worry things the the real sort of slow
decline that we want a show maybe more
than truth that we want a showman maybe
more than someone who's competent that
we it just may be a piece of what we've
all become that isn't something that's
able to do well to
in this sense it's not internet in this
sense I I've said all of my life the two
great calamities
in America were college and television
before College widespread college and
before television
Americans were more serious were more
mature were more grown up
that Oprah Winfrey is so popular
uh and and
is so not profound
you know well that's your truth
she's a big fan of that phrase
there's no such thing as your truth
the Oregon education department
announced that if you believe there's
only one right answer in math you're
you're a white supremacist
which by the way you know what the irony
of that that whole statement is if only
whites believe right that there's one
right answer in math then whites are
Supreme
that's the irony of the idiocy of that
black should be the first people to be
pissed at the Oregon education
department you're telling me that if I
think there's a one right answer in math
that means about white supremacist but
also to combine that to combine the yeah
mathematical truth right to to a racial
right yes yeah but we're hit with this
everywhere everywhere yeah so so
yeah I mean is it possible we're just
not serious enough as a nation at this
point then to to actually turn around
meaning that we want the thing that
gives us okay you know that the the my
the only thing that makes me pessimistic
is the aunts as as opposed to were
concerned yeah
is
uh free speech
the left
two things one there was no instance in
history and that was my field a leftism
at Columbia
uh there is no instance in history of
the left allowing descent
from you could argue from the French
Revolution certainly from the Russian
Revolution
wherever the left is in charge their
dissent is suppressed
there was no liberals allowed dissent
and conservatives allowed to send
leftists have never allowed descent
the so that that's that's Point number
one point number two
if the scent is allowed we will win
they can only win
by suppressing free speech
and I guess Point number three 45
of Americans say Young Americans say I
believe in free speech but not for hate
speech they don't even understand that
means they don't believe in free speech
right
if you want to say I am a Jew if you
want to say I hate Jews you should be
allowed to say I hate Jews because if I
don't allow you to say I hate Jews there
is no end to what I will not allow
that's why the anger the ADL which has
done more to foment anti-Semitism than
to fight it well they became a leftist
organization rather than a liberal
organization rather than a Jewish
organization yeah even that's right uh
so musk is correct in attacking the ADL
uh and now all the all these left-wing
Jews are calling him an anti-semite it's
so
it so angers me and I've written a book
on anti-Semitism which has been in print
for for 40 years what do you think of
the notion that every institution that
isn't specifically conservative will
always become leftists you know it's
fascinating there's a there's an actual
phrase for it but that you know in
essence like if you look at the ACLU
which was a liberal organization
defending the Nazis right to march in
Skokie Illinois
I've never thought of that that is a
very intelligent point
can I think of a liberal as opposed to
individual liberals like Alan dershowitz
right but can I think of a liberal
institution that has not gone left
I cannot and by the way a lot of the
conservative ones end up too but they
have at least some defenses right I mean
they end up liberal too they end up
probably shifting more left over yeah
promise to goodness conservative
institutions uh that's clear
but your point is frightening
but it kind of makes sense it does and
and look what you said about Colombia
well Colombia was was left when I was
there wasn't even liberal but the the
so that raises the important question
why does that happen why aren't liberals
guardians of liberalism
do you have an answer to that
I mean I've been noodling this one for
quite some time and it comes up on my
show all the time and I think it
probably is connected to belief that's
correct that's my ultimate thesis I see
no way around it there is you end up
believing in something you know when
I've discussed this with Bill Maher when
I hear him talking about it he always
says well I didn't leave the left the
left left me and then he says the
liberal principles he believes in but
he's also he also would say he's not a
Believer so he on one hand is telling me
I I believe in liberalism but if you
said him are you a Believer you know in
a grand sense he would say no but you do
believe in something you just told me
what you believe yeah but you you told
me just 10 minutes ago he supports
Newsom who's a leftist so I think he's I
think he's rather confused yes he is
well no it's not that he's confused he's
a brilliant guy the issue with him
really and I would we've become friendly
so I would say this to his face this
isn't something I'm not speaking behind
his back his issue I think is that he's
67 years old worth an Untold amount of
millions of dollars as a lifelong
atheist unmarried with no kids he can
afford to have certain beliefs that I
think maybe if he had had kids and
whatever I know that sounds very
judgment he discussed this a bit with
Jordan on on his podcast but you know
what I mean like if you're if you're
worth a gajillion dollars and only
responsible for yourself it's pretty
easy probably to have a series of
beliefs that don't really have to get
put into action he doesn't have to have
he's not worried that his kid's gonna
come home saying that his kid's a girl
his son is a girl so you can sort of
have the belief that it's wrong but you
can also vote in the guy who will Usher
it in
well it raises also other questions uh
like but I don't mean to make about him
no no all right well well
uh
Bill Maher when ABC kicked him off yeah
and he said disgusting things about
American Pilots I had him on my show to
defend his right to say disgusting
things so I have a long long track
record with Bill Maher but but the
liberalism Bill Maher that I would like
to live long enough and I hope I do uh
is 10 years from now will he look back
at a life with no no wife no kids and we
go that was a great life I I I don't
know the answer but
it it's it's not a it's not meant to
insult him at all at all because I
actually admire his taking on the left
but
it's it's a lack of emotional depth
let's put it that way
if you're 77 and go you know I really
had a lot of fun what a great life
uh and you know you should watch I'll
send it to you he did a sit down with
Jordan for about two hours and they they
got into this and it's a tough thing to
sit across from someone and talk about
it much less Jordan Peterson and I think
Jordan would even say Bill might be as
close to the ability to do that as
possible oh fascinating meaning he gave
everything to his career and his comedy
and it's not to say it's perfect because
Jordan basically would say it's almost
impossible which is in essence what
you're saying but Bill might be as close
Okay that's fair yeah I want to go back
to the question you posed and I then
posed to you
is why do all liberal institutions end
up left and uh your answer has been my
lifelong answer
and I hear here is part of the
reasoning we can give I just spoke at
Arizona State University again
oh I covered this on the show because
you're very controversial right you and
Charlie Kirk went there Robert white
nationalist yeah yeah yeah I know I lost
relatives in the Holocaust but I'm a
white nationalist so uh the
I said I said to them
uh one second this is this is really
important oh yes something I've been
saying for for years
only secular people say men give birth
that should really give pause to anyone
who dismisses the importance of the
Bible religion God Etc
only not all not everyone not every
secular person says men give birth but
everyone who says it is secular
so apparently there's infinitely more
idiotic ideas coming from the
non-religious world than the religious
world you are brainwashed to by the left
to believe that that it is religion that
is irrational and has cockamami ideas
and asks you to leave reason it's in
fact the secular world that has produced
far greater irrationality or as I say to
students all the time
you know 100 million people
non-combatants were murdered in the 20th
century and every one of them by a
secular government
that sort of feels like it should be the
ending but it was a little dark give me
something give me the Dennis Prager
Smiley I'll give you a question yeah
there we go okay
do you know oh yeah well you just heard
I just told it to you beforehand but
I'll say it again you'll just have to
laugh
we'll be even funnier people will get a
kick out of this I got I just I just
learned it because it was just my
grandson's Bar Mitzvah and and uh in
Florida and my son his dad my son told
the story to to the people at the bar
mitzvah party
prior to the the Sabbath rituals and so
uh he is known as dp3 I'm dp1 Dennis
Prager my son is dp2 David Prager and he
is Daniel Prager dp3 and he's very proud
of that which touches me he'll probably
be a basketball yeah so
uh when he was about eight my my son
told the story
uh he uh he said to his father Daddy
if I have a child or when I have a child
he's going to be dp4
so my my son asked The Logical question
oh really
why will you name him and he goes Dewan
which is you know I generally understood
to be a black name often associated with
sports yeah and that's that's which by
the way I don't know if I told you
inside it reminded me of of his dad my
son also at eight I said David what do
you want to be when you grow up and he
said black
because he had a picture of Magic
Johnson uh in in his room he skipped
basketball player and went right to
Black that's correct well that was the
only Avenue to do what he really wanted
presumably but it was it was so he is in
good tradition my grandson but that's
how we're gonna get dp4
and as much as I enjoy these highly
intellectually stimulating and deeply
personal philosophical yeah I also wish
that everything being equal I had been a
black basketball player so here we are
that is that is a confession that
no one has heard from you prior to this
how often do you fist bump
as often as I'm offered Fists
I love you Dave Ah that's good that's
good if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop screaming
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell